mueve el punto naranja a menos 54 y así
que tenemos un número complejo comparte
real en este caso será menos 5 y su
parte imaginaria será 4 muy bien además
este 4 está multiplicando ahí así así es
como estamos definiendo este número
imaginario y como nos piden graficar lo
en esta especie de ejes que no son los
ejes tradicionales sino que en el eje
horizontal tenemos que graficar la parte
real y en la en el eje vertical tenemos
que graficar la parte imaginaria así que
en este caso en nuestra parte real es
menos 5 nos vamos hasta menos 5 y la
parte imaginaria es 4 y nos vamos 4
unidades hacia arriba comprobamos la
respuesta ahí lo tenemos correcto vamos
con el siguiente digamos y se mueve el
punto naranja a 2 - si nos movemos a 2
nuevamente esta es la parte real es 2 y
la parte imaginaria es menos 1 verdad
menos 1 multiplica
y comprobamos respuesta lo tenemos
correcto muy bien ahora vamos a movernos
a 44 y nuevamente la parte real es 4 y
la parte imaginaria también es 4 así que
volvemos a subir ya nada más esto es
correcto vamos a hacer un último
ejercicio mover el punto a 5 menos 2 y
otra vez la parte real es 5 y la parte
imaginaria es menos 2 menos dos y
comprobamos nuestra última respuesta es
correcta